How long before we start seeing weight gain, this is a person that has some
cakexia that they are trying to gain weight. Yeah, that's difficult. You know,
cakexia is statistically one of the hardest things to deal with with with
later stage cancer from anybody's perspective, natural or standards of
care. There's just not really anything that you can do but you've got to start
eating some carbohydrates. So if you could just call the weight loss down, you're
waiting. So if the person's losing three to four pounds a week, no matter what
they're eating, and then down their weight has kind of stabilized, or they're
not losing any weight anymore, you are waiting. So just keep doing what you can do
and keep trying to get calories in and you have to be eating complex carbohydrates.